petite erreur d'aiguillage assure le
jingle bonjour sébastien dubois
bonjour monsieur lé ton bonjour à tous
les éditeurs de martigues première
déléguée départementale de françois
asselineau candidat à la présidentielle
française sous les couleurs de l'union
populaire républicaine
françois c'est une eau qui a présenté
son programme hier quelques heures à
peine après avoir eu confirmation
d'avoir atteint le nombre suffisant de
parrainages pour le scrutin votre
formation se targue de connaître une
progression constante
près de vingt mille membres et une
campagne essentiellement sur internet et
ça marche
eh oui force est de constater que ça
marche mais c'est pas un choix délibéré
de deux du parti de se développer sur
internet c'est c'est on a été obligé de
le faire comme ça puisque on a eu quand
même une carence c'est moins qu'on
puisse dire en termes médiatiques
jusqu'à aujourd'hui jusqu'à l'obtention
des 500 parrainages
acceptez-vous cette étiquette de petit
parti obligé de jouer des coudes pour se
faire entendre
mais en terme de deux parties on est pas
on peut pas être considéré comme un
petit parti puisque on a comme vous
l'avez dit près de vingt mille adhérents
fin 18000 on enregistre à peu près 300
adhésions par jour je pense pas qu'ils
aient beaucoup de partis politiques
aujourd'hui enregistré de tels scores et
si on compare à adé des partis comme
celui de monsieur dupont aignan par
exemple est ce qu'on va lui dire que
c'est un petit parti ou celui de
monsieur macron qui va bientôt dépasser
les 200 millions d'adhérents puisqu'il
suffit de cliquer sur le site internet
pour être adhérent
donc est ce qu'on peut considérer que le
site de monsieur macro et 1 0 un énorme
parc 0 logique lui père qui reste sur un
traîneau très précis un mouvement de
libération nationale française avec
sortie de l'union européenne sortie de
l'euro sortie de l'otan pourquoi autant
de velléités alors c'est en fait c'est
là c'est la conséquence on va dire
c'est ses deux sauts sont les remèdes
qui sont préconisées par suite à
l'analyse précise de la situation
politique en france c'est à dire que
françois asselineau a été en regarder de
près les traités européens et a fait le
diagnostic et en tire la conclusion que
si l'on reste dans l'union européenne
on va forcément vers la catastrophe et
c'est pas elle parle déjà de survie de
la france
oui tout à fait parce que le
actuellement les politiques la
souveraineté nationale ce qui n'est pas
un gros mot et ce qui n'appartient pas
non plus seulement à l'extrême droite
la souveraineté nationale n'appartient
plus au peuple c'est la souveraineté
nous a été dérobé par la commission
européenne
et ça on nous sommes les seuls à
l'expliquer mais de manière précise de
manière avec texte à la pluie toute
preuve à l'appui et vous est même allé à
dire que en cas de victoire de françois
seynod à la présidentielle française
vous re nationaliserait tf1 oui de ce
que tu es enfin c'est le premier outil
de formation de l'opinion publique en
france
7 cette entreprise est possédé par
bouygues qui est à son capital 20 % de
fonds de pension américain est ce on
estime que ce n'est pas normal que un
tel outil soit mis dans les mains
d'intérêts étrangers
alors revenons sur cette sortie de la
france de l'union
c'est une mesure que françois sino
appliquerait sitôt son mari va l'elysée
mais sortir la france de l'union s'est
également sortir la martinique de
bruxelles
une martin et qui a besoin de cette
manne financière pour sa banane pour sa
cave pour son économie
oui mais il faut savoir une petite chose
un petit secret forcément qu'il n'ait
pas beaucoup entendu c'est que les fonds
européens
c'est l'argent route c'est de l'argent
français puisque la france est un pays
contributeur net
elles donnent tous les ans 24 23
milliards d'euros à peu près à l'union
européenne et la sasp à 14 milliards
dont ce qui fait qu'il ya année 1,9
milliard de différentiel les pays
contributeurs nets donnent plus qu'ils
ne reçoivent nous ça veut dire très
concrètement que si la remerciera de
l'union européenne pour encore moins
oui mais de points communs nous on y
contribue beaucoup ça veut dire vous
faites que pour la martinique en
particulier les subventions qui sont
versés à la martinique pourront être
exactement les mêmes et on aura de
surcroît 9 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires pour faire du logement
social ou c'est ça votre internet si
vous lui donnez à l'union européenne
on leur donnerait aux régions ce serait
donner aux agriculteurs aux associations
sous forme de subventions mais avec le
drapeau tricolore pour parler de de
reprendre je lui bien écouter françois
séguenot hier lors de sa conférence de
presse vous parle également de reprendre
tout ce pouvoir donner aux régions trop
de décentralisation trop de
désintégration sein de cette république
française des régions qui pourraient
prendre trop d'initiatives avec la
complicité des technocrates de bruxelles
oui c'est à dire que nous nous voulons
simplifier le millefeuille administratif
en supprimant l'échelon régional qui est
un échelon qui a été rajoutée dans les
années quatre vingt 80 2 je crois et et
supprimer l'échelon européen pour
revenir à une situation administrative
qui soit l'état le département et les
communes
mais des pays comme le nôtre comme la
guadeloupe comme la guyane
des pays comme les nôtres ont plutôt
envie de pouvoir discuter d'égal à égal
avec nos voisins amis et frères de la
caraïbe
bien sûr mais ça va le faire toujours
les autres programmes comme le vôtre ils
pourront d'autant plus de fer qui sont
sortis d'une européenne vous savez
saint-barthélemy par exemple je sais pas
si les auditeurs le saint-françois sinon
est sorti l'union européenne qu'il y a
trop de pouvoir donner à ces régions que
tout doit être recentraliser que c'est
pas on parle pas de recentralisation on
parle simplement de de récupérer le
pouvoir souverain du peuple est d'avoir
une organisation qui correspondent aux
souhaits du peuple français c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui il a été programmé
on doit supprimer vingt mille communes
mais ça on a demandé l'avis aux citoyens
de savoir s'ils sont d'accord
vous savez beaucoup de décisions sont
posé la question et lui oui mais ça
c'est pas normal dans une démocratie et
sa danse à que le chapitre référendum
populaire est très important pour vous
oui c'est
le référendum d'initiative populaire
c'est quelque chose qui existe dans
plusieurs pays du monde et c'est quelque
chose qui est fondamentalement
démocratique c'est à dire que si la
population a envie de poser une question
est sur un sujet très président
notamment sur la question de la sortie
de l'union européenne par exemple le
peuple pourrait être en droit de
demander des visas nationaux
il suffirait d'avoir cinq cent mille
personnes qui se rendent à paraître sur
la question - par exemple ça peut être
une loi organique qui fixera les
modalités de tout ça mais ce référendum
vous êtes prêt à y avoir recours
même par exemple pour le principe de
regroupement de certaines communes oui
alors on n'a pas parlé d'interdictions
de fusion de communes parce que c'est
vrai que sur le territoire de la
république je parle pas assez de la
martinique aux particuliers mais il ya
des toutes petites communes de 100 150
habitants de son temps qui peuvent avoir
intérêt à fusionner entre elles on va
pas les interdire mais par contre il
faudra que ce soit voulu par les
populations donc sous forme de
référendum de questionnements mieux on
veut mettre un terme à la fusion forcée
voilà françois séguineau semble dire
qu'il faut que
l'état reprenne le contrôle de certains
nombre de choses mais en même temps il
dit que le mr dray est l'élu le plus
respecté est le plus qui a le plus de
pouvoir car c'est lui qui le plus au
contact avec la population ont pas le
plus de pouvoir mais c'est vrai que
c'est vrai que si on pose la question
aux citoyens lequel élus enquête lui ils
font le plus confiance
mais c'est le maire qui ressort avait
tout simplement parce que le mr cdh et
lui le plus proche d'eux des citoyens
aujourd'hui les réformes territoriales
qui on est et qui sont faites en vertu
de la loi un autre préconise de
d'éloigner les citoyens de la mairie
fasse ça revient à ça à une finesse et
quand on fait des collectivités de
communes décollé d agglomération de
communes bien ça veut dire que le
pouvoir il est emmené plus loin du
citoyen voilà nous on veut conserver la
proximité avec le maire une réforme
constitutionnelle
c'est ce que vous préconisez pour
restaurer le principe de complot contre
la sûreté de l'état tout comme ce
principe de haute trahison pour le
président de la république pourquoi
parce que vous avez regardez ce qui
s'est passé au cours des dernières
années
alors c'est vrai qu'on va profiter de la
réforme constitutionnelle que l'on va
proposer pour restaurer en effet le
crime de complot contre la sûreté de
l'état et le crime de haute trahison qui
ont été nettoyées de la constitution
dans le dos du peuple et à celles à qui
profitait cela eh bien justement c'est
ce qu'on se dit c'est qu'en fait le
crime de la criminal sion 2-2 de complot
cotation t2 d'état et d'autres à 10 ans
a été enlevé en 93 après maastricht et
juste avant l'élection de nicolas
sarkozy en 2007 sa nounou on estime que
ceux qui ont fait ça ont forcément une
idée derrière la tête
donc nous on va réinstaurer ces notions
là de complot contre la sûreté de l'état
et de crime de haute trahison
forcément c'est une lors de sa
conférence de presse est exprimée
pendant de très longues heures
hier et est à peine à peine quelques
secondes concernant les autres maires
pour dire qu'il faut mieux gérer les
ressources de nos pays c'est suffisant
pour convaincre les martiniquais ce oui
mais là il est dans un programme de
national donc c'est vrai que c'est
difficile de faire des cas particuliers
dans quand quand la là l'enjeu delà de
l'élection présidentielle c'est l'avenir
du pays
en tout dans son ensemble donc c'est une
vision de la france qu'est ce que qu'est
ce qu'on va laisser comme comme à nos
enfants nos petits-enfants dans dix ans
va tenter enfin avoir une vision de long
terme
donc ça qui est difficile dans un
programme surtout dans la situation
politique catastrophique que l'on
connaît aujourd'hui de parler de tous
ces débats mais il y a un volet
législatif dans lequel on pourra
justement beaucoup plus s'exprimer sur
les problématiques particulières et en
l'annonçait déjà les lui paiera des
candidats pour les législatives
en martinique au mois de juin quatre
candidats oui tout à fait merci beaucoup
d'abriter avec nous s'est passé du bois
on rappelle que vous êtes le délégué
départemental de france roissy nos
candidats à la présidentielle française
pour l'union populaire républicaine mode
journée bonne journée merci